[Applause]
hey guys hey welcome to the battlefield
5 show live from EA play in Hollywood
let's hear it
I'm Jerry RT and today we've got a ton
of new info on some of the great updates
coming to Bao feel 5 in 2019 but don't
just take my word for it
my co-host he reads all of your tweets
and I do actually mean all of them it's
a little bit creepy and weird
battlefield community manager Adam
Freeman what have you got for us Freeman
thanks yeah now I may be a member of the
battlefield team but as you know I'm a
fan I know you guys fan too and you're
gonna love what we've got to you today
so over the next half hour we're gonna
be bringing you content that's coming to
you over the next years we've heard what
you want
so today you're getting your first look
at a ton of multi new new multiplayer
maps features we know you've been
screaming out for and the arrival of a
new theater of war that's coming to
Battlefield 5 is 4 so when chapter 4 to
find the odds drops it's bringing so
much cool stuff so let's get to it
over to you Julia thanks Adam
that's right let's wait no longer and
tear the plastic of our first new map
marita let's check it out
[Music]
the Battle of Greece continues on the
Morita map allied forces are making a
last stand to hold the Axis army
sweeping through the region
[Music]
you'll deploy on a sloping mountain
ridge and within the tight streets of a
rural town
if the allies control the town but axis
troops are already on its fringes
the road down into the village is
crucial and you must fight to hold here
or risk losing control of the region
you'll always have tactical choices
nearby with a close proximity to other
key locations so keep an eye out for
them marita is an infantry focused map
where all four soldier classes will be
able to shine tanks and aircraft will
stand aside for intense infantry
gunfights and sneaky flanks in the
cobbled streets
Hills and multi-story homes means unique
vertical gameplay stay alert in this
steep environment as the Battle of
Greece rages on
to help give us even more details on
Marita
please welcome Ryan MacArthur from DICE
yeah so thanks for coming out Ryan
so obviously Marita looks amazing what
was the Maps inspiration well I think
that you know the team in in in LA that
put this together and they built the the
mercury map that that everyone saw
earlier this month and so they really
wanted to continue that story of the
bottle of Greece which is a bit of an
unknown story new to me as well as you
learn about this stuff so it's really
cool it's sort of set on the Albanian
Greece border sort of in the mountains
there were the the access power sorta
started to push into Greece during the
war and it sort of said above the clouds
in this nice little quiet well I guess
what used to be quiet village before
these guys all show up and it's a quite
a different experience than mercury and
a sort of a totally different style the
gameplay that you would have seen in the
game before so what kind of gameplay are
we talking about what's happening well
so this is gonna be a heavily infinite
infantry focused map so as mr.
battlefield likes to put it this is
total creative chaos so you're just
gonna see some creative chaos yeah so
what we get there was just head-on just
collisions in the middle of this map and
it's it's sort of a what we try to do
with all the new maps so we've been
created spending a lot of time to figure
out how do we make each one of them
different so when players go in and play
one of these new maps it has a different
feel than the ones they played before to
sort of create that different experience
for them so this one has I guess for
lack of better way to put it is sort of
a banana shape to it and that banana
well I think fruits important when
you're doing game design I think
obviously and so the shape gives you
sort of a variety of different play
styles and sort of creates the sort of
narrow channels for people to just run
head-on into each other which really
creates that that chaos that is
battlefield but that's what we want that
kind of chaos but most importantly we
need to know like we could talk all days
but when it could we get our hands on it
that's what we want to know right yeah
and I think the great thing for this
this is coming in July as part of
chapter 4 so stay stay tuned and I think
some people are gonna get to play it
while they're here today lucky you
alright Freeman who's we've stuck up
there for no other reason than well my
own entertainment has more on chapter 4
view over to Freeman I'm a pip etf Owen
I only give it out to me Julia listen we
have more maps so let's deliver a brand
new one to you this is Allison
is coming in Chapter four the fight
moves to the North African desert in a
vast new map for battlefield 5 al Sun
Dan prepare to engage alongside a lush
desert coast and contrasting harsh
environments Axis forces have
militarized the area with camps a radar
tower and an airbase you must fight over
possession of these critical points in
al Sun Dan we've taken the Vista used in
a single-player war story under no flag
and double down on air and land vehicle
combat with this the location has been
optimized for all-out multiplayer action
on this open map is up to you to shape
the fight with large distances vehicle
based team plane and battles across
ranges you'll always have plenty of
choices make good use of this sandbox to
secure the win utilize vehicles mounted
guns planes and transports capture the
strategic airfield to dominate the sky
or engage in fast-paced infantry battles
in tight interior areas al son Dan is
classic battlefield
we can't wait to let you play it
yeah that's amazing so what CL sundown
was adapted from an to know flag so tell
us a little bit about what that process
was like yeah so usually you know when
the guys say that when the team sort of
focus on building these war stories they
want to create these nice narrative
linear experiences and sort of that
really tell the story of World War two
but with with under no fly they sort of
took a little bit of a different
approach to this and sort of made this
big wide open experience and and that
showed a lot of potential from the
multiplayer perspective as well so when
we finished the game originally the team
wanted to sort of sit down and and and
sort of a small group of them and take a
shot at turning this into what could be
an amazing battlefield it's you dig map
this is your sort of classic battlefield
sandbox yeah this is where you're gonna
see you know tanks and planes and
infantry and all of that together in
sort of what is what is truly
battlefield it's sort of built for that
open-world gameplay with you know
depending on no matter how you want to
play there's something there for you
yeah oh definitely n tips so how to car
I kind of adjust my strategy because
it's such a wide map like what am i
doing well I think if you look at it
this room for all the from play style so
there's six flags on this one you're
playing conquest and you can see here
even if you can see from the videos here
you've got you know when you go into the
village it's all about infantry play and
speed and flanking through the things
and the bridge in the middle it's all
about you know sort of controlling that
with infantry gameplay and I think mr.
battle for the other day decided to just
sit there with his tank and not destroy
me but it's just something that he likes
to do he's kind of mean but he's not
mean he's nice but I mean again we could
go on and on over its height four types
there's so much to get you got 17 ounce
modes when can we get our hands on else
on that but so this is the first map
that we're gonna come in with chapter 4
so June 27th this is gonna be available
day 1 chapter 4 for everybody
nice nice now we got a couple more
surprises to come but before we get into
all that let's take a look at what's
coming in August towards the end of
chapter 4 get up close and personal
with chapter four defying the odds new
and intense close-quarter maps are
coming to battlefield 5
by popular demand we're bringing more
maps to players craving tighter types of
multiplayer specially tailored for
intimate infantry combat the new
battlefields would challenge your squad
in unique ways teamwork skill and
adaptation are your keys to victory
[Music]
fight through an explosives production
facility in luffa ten islands and unseat
the axis occupation in Provence
[Music]
prepare to assemble your team and rise
above your enemies and prepare to learn
more about these new battlefields later
in the year
[Music]
[Applause]
now to help us break down these new maps
ride and I are joined by mr. battlefield
himself last Gustafsson because he asked
nicely we also let Freeman point out
from his weird worse than my firestorm
teammates just leave me behind
everywhere do you want to take over this
one last these are very different than
to the two maps you've already shown so
far today
tell us about dr i mean thinking step
back we've been closely monitoring how
players engage in tides of war and and
no surprise something they love the
bigger modes like conquest it's always
been kind of a battlefield pillar but
it's been super fun to watch how they
engage with passion and dedication in
the small amounts like squad conquest
for example which really become a
success and with that in mind and we've
to get it with the dice la studio
they've been going at it
tailoring maps that are specially made
for small amounts and there's such being
able to give that you know the
close-quarter feeling they're tight what
you say the intimate combat oh yeah we
need that on vacation when we get back
what kind of like key strategies that
when you're playing but you know as we
see were these smaller game modes i mean
the key to this is just really good team
play a really good squad play and so you
know sticking together and not leaving
anybody behind like mr freeman over here
behind acceptable because I would it's
too beautiful as you saw Lofoten it's
serenity beautiful nordic countryside
but then kind of ripped open where the
campfire and everything amongst villas
and and factory equipment and then
Provence
you know I plan to take my wife there
you know Plus tents on the square Brian
beautiful you know lots of good flanking
your routes and it's the smaller Maps
really allows you to to master every
inch of its it's really about you know
knowing your battlefield I mean
again we could go on and on about all of
these lats but we've got one more map to
show off and I want to make sure we have
time to get through it but first last
you've brought with him some news about
some kind of core gameplay updates we
know that you've all been waiting for so
you're excited about this on this last
you know how much time we're spending
online like I mean I'm working
that's not delve big community features
we're going out this month increase the
max rank private games
let's talk max rank talk max rank we do
know and it's been loudly made to us
kind of awareness that there are players
out there too skilled who maxed out on
rank 50 too quickly so we've taken that
to heart and we now taken the max rank
from 50 to 500 so it's quite a leap and
it's moving forward and it's a grind
train but what are people getting if
they're on it yeah we're all in it you
know we want the goodies so to start
with already from rank 51 yeah you will
be granted the company coins for every
rank up but then at every to call them
milestone ranks you know every 50th rank
you will get one shiny new rank icon to
show off your skills and also beautiful
set of dog tags so lots of ways of
showing off your master you you own your
journey towards you know that the world
domination
it's the time so it's almost here what
was here it's a world domination for
large bio about world domination when
that what's happening right private
games then the other massive thing that
we know players one we got I mean
another one that for lovely community
have been vocal about and previously for
those who haven't been with battlefield
live what's called lorry speed they're
rented survey program but now we're
shifting over to private games and what
it means the beautiful thing with it is
the baseline package that come house is
free for everyone that plays battlefield
5 so a beautiful package its start to
let you set up your servers and and kind
of create your experiences where do you
want to capture or you know play with
your friends and Freeman you can play
with us which
Thanks you can sit with them obviously
you know you love getting all that
community feedback so hit him up mister
battlefield at aol.com let him know that
is the thing though like we're not
finished when we're done right no
exactly it's coming in let's see that
September member yeah and at that time I
mean we want you to dive on it set up
your servers play it and give us
feedback since this is kind of just the
beginning of the journey with the
private games we want to hear what did
we do right and where should we shape up
and and and take it an extra notch so
okay well don't don't tell Ryan but you
know you're my favorite for this thank
you very much for it we've got more than
Julia weird and fighting up well let's
promise we've got one more battlefield
map to show you it's called Operation
underground lars ryan talk us through
what we're about to see yes
let's say look well this is the the
ultimate definition of a passion project
so Inga you're on the the the original
designer front operation Metro when we
finished battlefield 5 and shipped it he
wanted to do something that he just just
was truly invested in so we kind of went
down and he sat down and he came back
with what was Operation underground and
when he showed it to the team we knew we
just had to make this and I think Lars
is sort of being part of that that
journey in the beginning I mean you know
how much this meant to the team yeah I
mean I was there when when we started to
build a mouse for battlefield 3 and
early on it was kind of a brainstorm I
still remember it was tons of images on
the world we challenged the team to you
know where do you want to fight
everything from subway to shopping mall
to dad knows everywhere yeah and then
the team started or someone smart not me
apparently I only get to pick one yeah
so they started to pick a number of them
and I think Engadine chose three of them
which was depart the subway and come to
the bank area in the city I mean you
don't want one meal you want three lots
of meals
yeah so you can see when you see kind of
it spinning in brown-nose here you can
see the true inspiration but what in
your run and the talented crew with him
has done is to to kind of take it hard
to feel
back from the original metro and started
to provide especially a lot of flanking
routes so that you can kind of move
around and be smart about it and tons of
easy to spot one I think as you look at
it like this is this is not Metro
remastered this is as the guys look at
this sort of reimagine and I think
you've got a bunch of different diverse
areas you've got big open courtyards you
know it's street level and narrow
streets and you go down into where you
see in the in the video here with the
but the subway cars are in into the sub
basements and you're going to find a
whole bunch of different things in
different ways to play in different
styles and I know that guys have a few
surprises in there as well that but I
think the community is really going to
enjoy when they get there so when when
do we get it question five this is the
one the team is really excited about as
well I know I can't wait for October
okay so I have a crack in time plan in
play test I'm so looking forward for
everyone else getting to play it too and
everything else that's on these new maps
oh yeah those sorry those are the only
surprise is this is the problem we've
got two months to get or just like stop
talking we've got so many surprises view
I say today we're giving you
never-before-seen details on battlefield
fives chapter 5 here's a little look at
what the team's been working on
[Music]
a timeless theater of war a new vision
prepare to deploy to the Pacific the
team at dice are hard at work creating
an iconic World War two experience
releasing this fool with Chapter five of
battlefield 5 as the u.s. and Japan
enter the fight
you'll clash across several battlefields
including a modern take on an absolute
classic Iwo Jima since battlefield began
the Pacific Theater has been part of its
DNA now we're crafting the ultimate
reimagining of the conflict by capturing
real-life environments and using the
power of frostbite we're bringing you
the Pacific realized with today's
capabilities and technology take part in
the u.s. invasions as they're
unstoppable forces charged inland
towards unwavering Japanese defenses use
new amphibious units to pummel the war
ridden shores and an expanded arsenal to
bring your squad to victory we have a
lot more to share about the Pacific and
how it will evolve battlefield 5 later
in the year stay tuned
okay most importantly you went on like a
bunch of like research trips like let's
find out more about that let's set that
one in Tahiti yeah that's amazing how
many people are willing to make that
extra effort to go to Hawaii and you
were in Stockholm yeah so it's quite
quite impressive we really appreciate
the team putting in that work oh yeah
but obviously I mean this is the big new
the big new addition to battlefield five
so going back new through to war in the
Pacific I mean this is this is a
homecoming for Lars I mean not even team
itself but this jokes aside it's you
know having been with battlefield 30
journey it's really where it all started
badly 1942
you know the Pacific Theater and already
when we started to talk about this game
the journey through the Second World War
everyone came up and kind of when do go
to the Pacific so this is the time it
feels like a homecoming 1942 but if in
1943 we've been there before but this is
in a new way and I think I think the
great thing I mean we hear a lot from
the community and I know you know we
have these discussions you've got where
my US forces where's my Japanese army
and you know can you sit here in LA
today and tell everybody that it's come
in Chapter five you're gonna get those
things you're gonna see some familiar
places like Iwo Jima
we've got two other maps coming with
that so three maps coming with the
initial package of the Pacific and
chapter five someone's I think that I
think people are gonna be really happy
with what they're gonna see and I'm just
saying some that you can hear from the
ping and the in the trailer some iconic
things as well Mike and it's coming
right we're living for the ping so we
wouldn't go TV Jima without kind of the
weaponry and the hardware so bringing
tons of iconic weapons gadgets and also
after all it's battlefields of course
there will be a new set of vehicles and
and we want to take that extra strap and
kind of start giving you the boats
fulfilling that sandbox of land air and
sea and the team has focused hard on
capturing
kind of that invasion experience I mean
it was very much about island hopping
during the wars
capturing deviation experience and the
amphibious warfare so there's tons of
new stuff and a new gameplay to look
forward to and beautiful locations thank
you both very much for joining us so
you've lost track of all of these brand
new battlefield announcements I don't
blame you because honestly there was
quite a lot so do you want to give us a
little bit of a recap there she went
I'll leave that on your capable
shoulders they come back of the balcony
but yeah go on go out there okay okay
we've got a load more multiplayer maps
then coming in 2019 that starts with
Alice and Dan on June 27 followed by
Marita in July we'll bring in a brand
new filter of water battlefield 5 the
Pacific that's releasing this fall we're
also bringing features we've heard the
community ask for an increase in max
rank from 50 to 500 and private games
also one final announcement starting
today you can play battlefield 5 in the
EA and origin access vault and through
EA access on PlayStation 4 when it
launches next month is that everything
pretty much covers it I guess you won't
be stay down here with them on the
adults table whatever
yeah I'm Julie Hardy and I'm freeman and
if you're in the Los Angeles area be
sure to come and visit us in person at a
play goodbye